Marvel ousband en résidence à la
batterie pour un grand concert funk le
groupe invocation instrumentale au
départ recherche de l'écriture de leur
premier album en 2010 un chanteur au
groove détonnant la rencontre avec
l'américain Wolfgang walgrumes résonnera
alors comme une évidence
pour un nouveau chanteur et voilà il est
arrivé il nous hallucinés avec sa voix
incroyable à la James on a dit oui tout
de suite quoi
la formation au complet compte depuis 9
musiciens les marvelous se définissent
comme un gros aux influences résolument
funk et saule issus de la musique noire
américaine des années 60 l'expérience
musicale de chaque membre en fait
également un groupe hostile emprunt de
rythme jazz rock et hip-hop
la résidence qui leur permet de
travailler leur prestation scéniques
dans les vraies conditions d'un live son
professionnel ça s'entend on voit très
bien que sur toute la partie musicale
c'est dans la boîte ça joue vraiment
très très bien on se dit que
musicalement tout est en place après il
faut maintenant trouver une façon de le
présenter au public qui soit optimisé et
donc on va on va mixer le placement les
lumières mais aussi parfois le choix de
l'ordre des morceaux de façon à ce qu'il
y ait vraiment une dynamique qui soit
créée autour de du concert et que
vraiment on optimise ce que l'on va
présenter au public
le résidence ne durera que deux ou trois
jours les répétitions auxquelles nous
avons nous assister laisse d'ailleurs
entrevoir un show déjà parfaitement
maîtrisé
les marvelous seront en première partie
du concert funk le samedi 9 février à la
batterie de Guyancourt